sound rollin take to others the other
marker so I was asked an interesting
question last night what do I think is
the best Alien movie out of the
franchise and my answer which is the
correct answer is of course the original
alien one of the reasons for this is
that alien contains what I think to be
one of the greatest fourth wall breaks
in the history of cinema I said this in
in my answer which was posted on ask fm
and a bunch of people have Ventura and
ask well hey Dan I don't know what you
mean what fourth wall break in Alien and
that's kind of my point it's so good you
don't even know it's there so here's the
scene in question see if you can spot it
normally we conceptualize breaking the
fourth wall as characters talking to the
audience through the fourth wall of the
screen through the fourth wall of the
stage however this is not you know the
only way that the fourth wall can be
broken in this case the diegetic world
of the movie has been broken by the
operator the camera is a mechanism of
the storytelling construct it does not
exist within the same space as the
characters so when the camera operator
pulls back and hits the wind chime and
ash then reacts to that he's reacting to
something that could not physically have
happened within the universe that he
occupies there is no motivating thing to
have triggered the wind chime so there
you go that's the great fourth wall
break-in in Alien by that guy what's his
name
Ridley Scott so that's the great fourth
wall break in Ridley Scott's alien as
always you can send me any questions
you've got on Twitter though I now also
have a ask fm page set up linked to the
Twitter so those can those can cross
chat and if you've got a question that's
got a little bit longer a little bit
longer of an answer that's needed
something that wouldn't quite fit on
Twitter that's a great way to do it all
right
fooling ideas season 5 question my
question my question Maxime one sin one
sin one